[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan's here i know everybody gets
excited right hello hello hello hello
hey people are more excited that you're
here then you're excited about being
here
is that possible i'm excited to be back
right yeah it's nice it's nice it is
your voice just got high it's good what
do you mean
uh it's just uh you know it's been it's
been a good week you know
i'm appreciative and after hearing about
this next guest it just
makes you kind of think i asked him a
lot of questions and i think we got some
great stuff here
uh i'm just really excited about this
normally i talk about
first i want to say thank you for all
the people who are supporting uh
stage it and my patrons who support the
podcast more than
amazing i talk about it all the time if
you uh don't know what patreon is out
there it's uh if you want to support the
podcast in other ways and get cool stuff
and have
you know get to ask questions to guests
and get to ask me questions i do this
thing ryan
you've seen it where uh it's called
inside of me where
you know people ask me questions and i
instead of just answering them i
create characters like i was in drag and
i was this
australian english guy because my accent
was all over the place and
so i try to have a lot of fun we do
youtube lives where it's like request
lines where
i play songs and for all the patrons
it's just it's amazing community
amazing friendships have come out of it
something i never expected
and uh it's just an awesome awesome
thing so thank you to all the patrons
out there keep supporting the podcast
thank you for listening
if you're just listening for the first
time i i hope you'll uh
give the show a chance subscribe uh
follow us um
at insideepodcast on instagram and
facebook and at ins
at insideyoupod on twitter
and it goes a long way it goes a long
way with your support and we keep
cooking
you know what is it i always say the
little caboose that could what was it a
little engine that could a little engine
that could
never get that right i did that play in
kindergarten you did yeah
how were you were you the engine no i
was uh no they
they made up a role for me that's
because you were so
good i think it was a caboose i think
they made up the caboose all right well
fine
see the caboose did exist then at least
in your uh yeah i like that
uh thank you guys also for watching our
stage it's we do live performances on a
thing called stagey.com
fioda rosenbaum and danson we have two
shows coming up
um august 29th two shows saturday
pacific time 2 p.m
6 p.m we play music we have prizes you
can zoom with us win
shirts and everybody just gets together
and we play covers and some songs from
my band left on laurel and we play
there's some originals that rob and i
are working on
so go to stage.com uh go type in
rosenbaum and dance and get a ticket and
hang out with us i hope everybody's
staying healthy i know it's just getting
crazier and crazier uh there's a light
at the end of the tunnel
and uh you know speaking of which after
talking to my next guest
boy it just puts things in perspective i
wish that when
when i have insight or i get this
insight from other people or
certain perspectives that i wish they
stayed with me longer because
they sort of they stay there and you're
like fascinated and go i need to be in
nature i need to
disconnect and then i want to do that
and then you get caught up in your stuff
again
and as you talk you hear this guy's
story i don't think there's been a
better story i just don't and he's not a
big celebrity he's
he won season six alone and
i was so fascinated by it i'm in tears
at the end of this finale
that i just instagram direct messaged
him like people do to me all the time
i don't check mine all the time and nor
did i think he would check his ryan
but i said hey man you know i played
obviously a a character who is a badass
but you're a badass in real life can
you would you talk with me yeah man here
email my sister
all right so i emailed rachel and she
was awesome and she's like yeah and i go
can you send me a bio she just sent me
some information like
oh yeah he should just jump on freight
trains for a year and go across the
country with his brother and he went to
siberia and
what at 21 and uh it's just
it's just i don't know it's it's a
beautiful story and it's kind of uh
i don't know it really i think you and i
got really excited after this interview
it's insane it's insane you didn't know
anything about it absolutely i have a
feeling you're gonna probably go watch
alone season six now i might now i'm
gonna have to
it's the arctic it's it's unbelievable
and his story is unbelievable like i
said so again guys thanks for supporting
the show i hope you like it
i'll be giving shout outs to my patrons
afterwards
and um uh big news coming up i still
can't
say it but there's some great stuff
coming uh our way here on the podcast so
uh please subscribe do all that stuff i
love you i'm gonna
be short get to the point let's get
inside of jordan jonas season six winner
of alone
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside
of you with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
of course you're out in nature yeah the
only place i can get cell service out
here i had to go on this mountain
my gosh so my one of my friends was like
my friend danine she's like
you love this [ __ ] watch alone
and i go what's alone i'm always alone
that's the story of my life i'm alone
i'm at home alone surviving so i can't
imagine i i
started here's what happened i'm one of
those guys that skips ahead i never read
when i'm supposed to read i just kind of
jump ahead to like the last chapter find
out what happens at the end
yeah yeah so i watch season six alone
there's seven seasons the seventh one is
is in they're doing it now yeah yeah and
i watched
six and all i could tell you was i
didn't leave the house till it was done
and i thought a couple things one i am a
[ __ ]
i also thought my gosh how brave are
these people and then thirdly i said
i cried when when when your wife comes
behind you at the end yeah me too dude
i'm telling you and i immediately go i
gotta get this guy on the show i gotta
get this guy in the podcast
this guy's awesome he's like the man
that i've always wanted to be
he faces so much adversity and like uh i
think you know there's a lot of jealousy
here
because the man that you are there's
uh you know the family how family
oriented how you could survive that long
77 days right
yeah yeah it ended up being not too bad
a couple months
i mean what i noticed about all the
other contestants it felt like you know
there was one guy who was flipping out
just flipping out and he was going
insane you know i don't
think i ever saw i mean you you know you
get a moose you will talk about the
the moose but like i never saw any
anxiety really from you
there was it felt like you were just so
even killed and some people could say
well those people are like those are
serial killers when they don't have any
kind of
emotion you know but i think it just
surprised me how
calm and the only thing i could tell you
was at the end i remember you going well
if i don't find any fat look my mind's
all right but i
i'm done right right oh yeah so
the whole thing just blew me away and so
this show really thanks man
that's cool yeah so you're into it
listen i'm into it i'm babbling now
because i'm excited it's like
i'm talking to a movie star here so i
mean look
the first thing i look at is like for
you to be who you are
that had to come from either your family
is completely dysfunctional and you were
sort of on your own and learned survival
skills or they were so damn cool
i i don't know tell me about it how was
your childhood yeah unfortunately
for me it was the latter i better have a
great family and like you know
mother and father and siblings i get
along with really well so it gave me a
good
pretty good solid foundation that
allowed me to move out in the world
and do kind of crazy things and you know
you kind of know you have
something to fall back on so what was
that
so yeah talk to me about that i mean how
did you become so fearless and what was
it how old were you when you realized
you had something inside you that wasn't
like all your other friends
uh um i guess the i guess probably when
i i started writing
well not starting right but my brother
rode freight trains a bunch
all around the country you know kind of
hoboed it up and then my
at the same time my older sister you
know i was the youngest so i got to
watch them all do these things my older
sister
lived in new york city and kind of was
in the high fashion world and you know
had
kind of the opposite end of life
experience so
as being the younger brother i was able
to watch both them
do these kind of opposite but crazy
things and
and join in a little bit so i rode
freight trains with my brother
for a summer you know we rode across the
country
up and down the east coast and then back
to uh
to my home basically and part of that i
did on my own so like we stood up and i
rode
by myself spent some time by myself and
then
i went up and lived with my sister in
new york for some months and had that
whole
opposite end of the spectrum experience
and i don't know after
doing those types of things you kind of
just don't want to go back to a normal
day job so you try to forge a new path i
guess
yeah but who who gets the idea i mean
what what appeal does it have i mean
me as a kid taking a freight train
jumping
what are your parents saying like oh
yeah go on the freight train yeah take a
freight train
how old are you when you're doing this
man i was like 19
so i was already old enough to make my
own decision
sort of i guess no but the uh i was
mostly because my brother had been doing
it but he had already been doing it
for years and he uh just invited me
along and i'd
like a normal person just been working
at the old
salad dressing factory doing my normal
job and
uh hopped out with them and
and man it was a whole new it was kind
of a whole new eye-opening experience
because you just
are out in the world every night uh you
know trying to
find what you know each day brings
something new and it uh
kind of gave me a taste of freedom that
i then
sought out in life probably but my
you know my mom by that time was used to
it because my brother had already been
doing it so she'd already
waved her hand i mean but
usually you think of like cowboys or old
you know
rebels back in the 18th century jumping
on freight trains
it's illegal what you're doing right
so the train's going do you usually wait
till a train stops or you just jump on
it let's go
well to avoid waiting too much we would
usually yeah wait
jump on it a lot of times when it's
moving slowly
run up alongside it grab onto the ladder
and hop on
and you know of course you're picking
out a car that has a good spot in it to
lay down in or ride on and and
see where you end up did you bring
snacks did you bring snacks to couples
some cans of chili oh we also made a
bunch of made a bunch of stew and like
put it in ziploc bags and then you know
you bite off the bottom of the bag and
squirt in your mouth
[Laughter]
i mean you know i mean and jeez man i
can't even and so you get arrested so
what would they do
they'd say what are you doing like hey
we're just and they just let you go
riding a train yeah they just had us you
know spend a night in jail and then
i guess that taught us a lesson and let
us go
nothing were you a troublemaker were you
a troublemaker in high school
really not at all huh i'm not just
uh well yeah i wasn't wasn't doing it to
try to get in trouble i'll just do it
[Laughter]
to have an experience i guess i don't
know i mean did you did you have any
kind of like when you were a kid did you
were you picked on at all or were you uh
were you popular in school
not really we uh i know i have you know
a lot of good friends kind of
i was homeschooled for my younger years
and then in high school went to
you know public high school but i had
good friends and a relatively normal
life
and so uh yeah i don't know
you know we grew up on a little farm in
idaho i guess
i don't know i mean when were you
hunting when when did you start hunting
or learning how to hunt and
uh i didn't do a lot of hunting growing
up my dad didn't hunt so
so mostly i got into that uh in
in siberia when i was with the natives
right
so siberia yeah you would you know
i mean what the hell how old were you
when you decided to to leave idaho
you're done with the freight training
you're looking for the next level
so we uh i was about i think i was 21
when i went to siberia the first time
about the 20
turned 22 so uh
yeah i went over there hey hold on one
second one second you got it what's up
okay go tell her not to she can't come
up here
hold on i'll tell her olivia
don't don't come up here
make sure you guys stay down there okay
you guys stay down there i'll say hi
later don't climb up hey kids
all right you know what i'm thinking the
first thing i'm thinking is
your attitude right then i have a
feeling that's your attitude
that you're so level-headed where i'd be
like olivia for the love of god
i'm doing an interview with someone i
don't know
what i mean are you always that even
killed or is your wife
sort of like at this point she knows you
but like
was she waiting for the crazy to happen
or she's just i think i think i'm
in general pretty even keel on that
front yeah
yeah that's a personality trait probably
south siberia you're you're 21 years old
what makes you go i'm going to go to the
coldest place in the world i'm going to
be miserable
this sounds nice huh no i uh i uh
you should write the brochures is it not
miserable
no it's pretty miserable but not in a
way
it's uh there was a there was a guy who
was over there building an
orphanage and i heard about him through
kind of a long convoluted story
and i decided to go over there and help
him so i i
basically just bought a ticket for a
year because i figured you know i'd
spend a good
long year over there felt like it was my
like calling at the time the right thing
to do so i went over there
and uh yeah spent a year there but i
i the guy building the orphanage was a
uh
like a missionary guy and he was an
american and i wanted to live with
russians so he spent sent me to a
neighboring
village where i kind of spent most my
time with a couple russian families
who uh who they had both spent some good
time in prison
and and in prison had met a uh
friend of theirs who was a native
reindeer
you know reindeer herding person and
introduced me
that was the long story of how i got
connected to the uh
reindeer herders up north i mean
was it the appeal that they were in
prison before that made you want to
live with them no well
now they were actually really cool guys
they were super
both of them were you know they're kind
of like classic russians and that they
have like
a couple cows and some animals and
cut hay with their you know that would
help them get hay in and they'd pile it
not in hay bales but in those like
piles that you see from the 1800s like
little
i don't know piles of hate no no we'd go
out and hate i don't know it's kind of
felt like real
the real village russian life and i i
liked it and they kind of just became
like my
you know russian version of a family so
and i bounced between them the one guy
was more like uh
serious and put together and the other
guy was just hilarious so both of them
were fun to
hang out with did you learn russian or
did they speak good english or was
everyday like oh was the hardest part i
felt like
probably the isolation learning russian
was almost more intense than
than on a loan and shows like you know i
felt like
the worst of it was learning the
language you know
uh isolation-wise so
alone didn't even feel quite as bad you
know i'd lived there for a whole year
and kind of just
slowly learned as i was there and they
didn't speak any english so it was
pretty
pretty intense so eventually it came
how how how much russian do you know
right now quite a bit i can pretty much
say anything i want to say
and have any conversation you know
fluent but i have
probably a bad accent and poor grammar
all right let me hear something let me
hear uh my name's jordan jonas i'm the
winner of season six alone i'm a badass
in russian
yeah jordan
[Music]
that's incredible how many languages can
you speak just two
english and russian yeah yeah wow
now it's just it's just amazing how like
you know someone
their sort of vision of what they want
to do
even if they don't know what's out there
to go explore
i envy you that because you know i'm 48
and i haven't really done that much i
mean right i went to college
you know i barely got through that i
mean i don't know
uh but like you you didn't go to college
right you said i'm going to freight
trains and go to side barriers you know
i got
two years at college in so yeah yeah and
you didn't like it
you didn't like it yeah i don't know i
didn't have a goal for it so it would be
just
doing it to do the rounds but i didn't
have like a it wasn't really a means to
an
end so i didn't really see it through so
yeah was your goal just to like i'm
gonna go help people build an orphanage
uh be a good person be
it you know and i'm just gonna do this i
was just trying to follow my
uh christian path as i saw it at the
time so i was trying to like uh
do that the best i could i guess as we
all try to
live our lives the best we can and i and
i that's all
that's what that was basically my
motivation and then
you learn a lot as you go i guess and uh
yeah i don't know it's kind of one foot
in front of the other type thing
but it just blows me away because it's
like
you know you had good i don't know role
models your parents you had a good
family you went on freight trains you
went across the country you were taking
chances you went to siberia you learned
russian you built
it's like you're doing more in like the
first 21 22 23 years of your life than
most people have ever or will ever do
you realize that right yeah i don't know
yeah that's weird i haven't i haven't
thought of it in that way but it was i
guess a pretty action-packed
couple of decades i don't know
especially in my 20s and stuff you know
yeah i mean
when you have you done have you done
anything in your life where you're just
like
i can't do this is there anything you've
tried
that you're just like you know you win
season six alone on the arctic which is
unbelievable which we'll get into here
in a minute
you go to siberia you learn russian
nobody speaks russian how the hell do
you even learn russian if no one could
teach you how to speak russian
it's like how do i say hello i don't
know what the hell you do
so it's like what's one thing you just
that you've tried
you know what oddly enough maybe it's
like
when i went over there too i was pretty
young and in a way you're kind of
idealistic and i wanted to
and you i really fell in love with the
native
way of life and the native people you
know they became some of my really close
friends
but then you kind of feel helpless in
in in you want to help them but i don't
you know i don't really know how
you don't really know how and maybe
that's something that i've tried several
times in several ways to try to
you know raise money or you know just
help by
being there and setting up certain
systems that might give them uh an
advantage in
in life and and generally failed
you know as far as like as far as doing
uh something that was
impactful in his in it on the level that
i
would hope you know although things are
always impactful on small scales and you
know relationships and this and that but
you know i was always hoping to i
sometimes some ways i view that way of
life as as it may have been in like
1860s native america where
where there's still a lot of people
living the old ways but they're also
under siege from a lot of
both internal and external forces and
you know you kind of want to like help
them make it through
and and and thrive and
i haven't found an effective way to do
that on a broader level
yet although we've tried several times
in several ways
wow but it's probably a lifelong and
mini lifelong
task you know but yeah did they so is
that where in siberia is that where you
sort of learn how to trap and you
learned how to like
have started hunting that was living
with the natives you know watching them
do what they do and
being a part of it so yeah
definitely like living off the fat of
the land learning how to survive just
based on
yeah and really it's people doing it
who've been doing it for generations so
it really separates all the wheat from
the chaff of what you might
you know want to learn if you were just
trying to pick it up here in the states
and watching
you know videos or going to classes and
stuff it's like
you don't know if they're teaching you
really works or what you know but
yeah that was that was
the big lesson out there i would say
where i learned a lot of that stuff
were you ever like at some point when
you were in siberia
or you're doing all these things and
you're lying in your bed and you're
looking up at like
i don't know what you're looking up at
like wouldn't whatever
are you ever thinking f this i i want to
go back home to the states
oh in siberia there were there were a
couple times where i was
really miserable due to like some kind
of ins either
injury or uh
whatever else uh that that i was pretty
they're pretty rough feeling pretty
rough but and then there's times that
are you know we had a
real a real like you know kind of
times when your friends die or something
like that over there where you're just
like man this
place is brutal you know but uh
i don't know i can't yeah i actually do
remember now that you say that i
remember laying
in my bed and this actually was early on
when i was still learning the language
but i just remember laying there and
thinking man i wouldn't wish this on
anybody
but that was like my that was like my uh
isolate the feeling of isolation that i
was going through at the time
yeah yeah to answer more specifically
your question and there were a lot of
other times where i was really miserable
but i don't remember specifically
thinking like
ah like i wish i could tap out or get
out of you know like
uh i guess you just know you're in it so
you just go through it but
yeah did you ever like were did you ever
get any fights in siberia were there any
guys russian guys or like who's this
american guy
did you ever feel like anybody was
picking on you or everybody was cool uh
no not really i definitely like cussed
out a few times
but you know usually almost i guess
every time i would say it was just
somebody real drunk
you know and there was a guy that pulled
a knife
on me but he was super drunk and not
that threatening
and then yeah it's all it's always it's
always that uh
i had a couple there were a couple
native guys that got in a big bra
one time and i was like sitting out in
front of the teepee and i just hear
and then all of a sudden all the kids go
running out of the tp everybody's
running and things those guys come
falling out of it
like wrestling over this you know this
gun it's like a sks kind of like an
ak-47
they're wrestling over i was like holy
crap but you know the bullets were just
whizzing over our heads and i
ran over there and like unloaded the
magazine really quick while they were
wrestling around and then let him
continue wrestling
but that wasn't really directed at me
but uh
there are definitely a lot of like
chaotic moments
dude i love it i mean so were your were
your parents kind of like
uh jordan i love you i'm proud of you uh
they were patient with you they just
whatever you want to do
the world is your oyster that's how you
felt yeah i definitely felt supported by
them for sure they were just like you
know if that's what you feel like it's
the right thing to do
you do it and whatever the risk or
whatever so yeah
they they were pretty supportive on that
front
yeah that's that's insane i just like
for me i always talk about this but i'm
like
my father had no patience with me i mean
maybe i was a little addi
all over the place but there was never i
don't remember a moment where he said
listen
i'm proud i am take your time
it's gonna i never heard that [ __ ]
so it's a wonder why i had to get into a
profession where i know it's just crazy
the difference that i can make you know
my dad was really encouraging really man
you're doing a great job
it's so yeah you have to overcome
something else right
wow what was it like the first time you
hunted or you
ended up you know honestly like killing
an animal was that something like was it
a weird feeling were you
how did you feel about it you know when
you're when you're
naked especially you feel really a lot
more a part of the cycle of life in a
weird
way like you know like death feels a
little bit more natural and it also
feels a little bit more
apart of things so i remember even just
killing their own reindeer at times you
know when they wanted to butcher them
and stuff and they're like
animals and stuff you've been taken care
of and this and that but
you know there's just a time for
everything and you realize your time
will come
too and you know it's just kind of it
feels more like because you're around it
all the time you're always seeing
animals die or this or that happen it
just uh
it you you're you you feel more it feels
more a natural part of the process i
think
yeah i could tell that was the thing
that was a thing i definitely noticed
oh there it was just like oh even like
death amongst them it's as sad as
anywhere you know like
we don't want to lose loved ones but it
was but it kind of
felt more part of the cycle i think for
whatever reason just because your whole
life is surrounded
by it because it's always with the
animals and the
yeah yeah well i i could tell
when you were in the arctic and when you
when you
shut when you shot the moose with an
arrow i could tell you were like
the one thing i knew about you is you
didn't want to see any animals suffer
and you couldn't get in there because
it's dangerous it's this giant moose and
while he's still going you're gonna
you're risking your life so
as much as you wanted to get in there it
sucked to watch him have to suffer right
definitely absolutely yeah yeah i would
have loved to put him out of his misery
but it just wasn't
a realistic option like the most likely
option is he would have
seen me because at the moment when i
shot him he didn't really know what hit
him he just
felt something in his side and ran off
and laid down and
and if he then sees you sneaking in to
try to finish him off
then he knows he's being chased you know
and then he'll get all this adrenaline
and fear
and jump up and run away and you might
never find him again and then he would
die in vain
or he might jump up and decide to attack
you
you know which moose do and so it's like
either way it's a bad scenario whereas
if he kind of just calmly
goes out he doesn't really know he was
being hunted you know you could tell he
was looking around he wasn't that like
panicked and nervous you know yeah it
was kind of a strange but yeah
it i did i wished i could have made it
happen faster but
yeah your wife i mean good lord i mean
when you said you were gonna do this
was she completely supportive or like
jordan
no you have kids we're not what are you
doing
right well it was kind of she kind of
knew it was a
perfect opportunity for me like i think
i think
my wife and my some of my you know my
siblings were probably more confident
than i was they were just like oh you
got this man this is the perfect
situation for you uh and you know of
course i'm just like i don't know
we'll just see what happens but uh the
she was also
in that boat where like man can almost
not say no just because
it's such a good opportunity you know
our usual work is just
dirty nasty demolition and stuff and
like even the year before the alone show
working i'd fell off a ladder and broke
both
my arms so that was rough so my wife had
no
you know knows that my day job doesn't
go by without
its own inherent risks and stuff so
so i think she felt like it was kind of
the perfect situation for me
and so she was pretty supportive i i
think in the end she had a harder time
than i did
with the kids you know but but that's
understandable i guess
did you think you'd last 77 days did you
think
did you think it would take 77 days what
were you thinking in the back of your
head like
huh that's a good question like i
actually thought
i honestly told myself the show would by
no
in no way and before day 90. so i didn't
even think the show
and i had convinced myself so soundly
that i
that i thought at day 90 is basically
when the show is gonna start and then
we're gonna
see who can stretch out the farthest
from there you know so i thought maybe
i i thought in the back of my mind i was
allowing myself like well if we get
today 120 then i think i'll win
but i should i should allow myself to
get to day 140 and then
but then when i started thinking about
day 140 that's when i started getting
stressed man i don't have enough fat
i don't have enough this or that you
know so that's where a lot of my
worry about my food situation came from
was thinking i had to make it
140 some days what was your wife
honestly 77 was a lot shorter than i
expected
i remember like watching and you uh it
was almost like i don't know if you ever
saw reservoir dogs were
yeah you know when tim roth is looking
in the mirror and he's like you got this
you're so [ __ ] cool
you're so [ __ ] you got like there was
an element where you were like
he wants to convince them that he's part
of their group so i think you were
convincing
like you were gonna say you're about
getting ready for the helicopter to come
down
and like check you out to see if you can
stay because they were kicking people
off if they've lost a certain amount of
body fat
so you i remember when you're talking
you're standing there and you're going
were you nervous that they're gonna tell
me i have to go and be like hey look i'm
skinny i remember you going i'm skinny
all right look i'm thin
but i'm tough i could i could handle
this
what were you thinking like were you
unfortunately i didn't know what they
were thinking so and i didn't know how
much i weighed they didn't show us our
weight and so i just had to guess
and i was like i just looked at my gut
and i was like well i still got a gut so
i
can't be that thin you know like but i
don't know what they're thinking because
you know here we are they are doing an
extra medical check
because that's what their i guess their
reason for bringing janet lee out was
and i just thought they were doing an
extra medical check because they were
concerned and so i was just like no
way you guys can't be concerned and then
i like couldn't sleep at night i was
like they can't really be worried about
me you know and so i was
but i was panicked that they were
so then i like thought for several days
about what i was gonna tell them when
this medical check came like i'm totally
fine you guys can't blah blah blah what
do you want me to do push-ups jumping
jacks
yeah so i was in the mid-sentence trying
to convince him that i was
my normal self because you know they
don't know what that is
and so uh that's when jana lee came up
yeah
when she came up behind you because i i
didn't see i mean
did you feel that emotion hit you when
you saw her oh yeah i was shocked i mean
that was that was like
most shock i could feel i was a
again i didn't expect it at all i hadn't
hadn't like
given myself that glimmer of hope at all
yet i was just like
i was just like so i was totally shocked
i couldn't believe it
and i was so happy to see her you know
like the whole time
i was thinking man it'd be so cool if my
wife could come up here it would be so
nostalgic for her
you know because it's similar to siberia
and she'd been there
and uh and that's just what you think
about the whole time so
it was kind of a culmination of that but
it was also kind of a culmination of
like
sort of your wildest dreams i wasn't
really i'd never allowed
i think just psychologically i didn't
want to allow myself to think i was
going to win because you don't want to
be that disappointed
yeah just like i'm probably not going to
win you know blah blah blah
and i just talked myself into
i'd kind of already and i think it was
good for for your mental state but i'd
already kind of convinced myself
of the worst possible outcomes one that
it would go a lot longer
and two that i wouldn't win but then i'd
come to terms with those you know i was
working on
coming to terms with those like okay
it's okay if it goes
an extra another couple months it's okay
if
you don't win baba you know like so i
was trying to come to terms with the
worst things so that i could only be
uh pleasantly surprised and that's
really what happened
how much food did you have when they
came to give that extra checkup on you
did you have a fish in your
i had a couple hundred pounds of moose
still and i had like
six i think i had five fish so like 60
pounds of fish
probably well okay hang on cause they
make it seem like you didn't have any
food
yeah yeah that was that was you know
they got to create suspense
but you were fine yeah i had a lot of
food i had
the wolverines still to eat i probably
had 10 rabbits hung up i had like
i just had tons of food at the moment
you know
and the fat was dwindling like a lot of
that food isn't like
loaded with fat but i still had lots of
fat i still had plenty of fat for
another
month or two you know did you smell like
just ass
i smelled like like moose and smoke
and i don't know if that's too bad it
was i kind of my clothes that i still
have that smell like that i'm like
that's kind of a good smell
that's your new nickname moose smoke
did your wife say you smell yeah you
know what
i think when you live in the woods for a
long time like obviously if you take a
shower and then you like go out and
you're running around for a couple days
in new york you'll stink
but then if for whatever reason if
you're in the woods
over months and you don't take a shower
you
your body must like neutralize somehow
it doesn't really
stink and even my wife said that it's
just weird you know i don't know what it
is
but she wanted you to shower you don't
really have b.o
for whatever weird reason but she wanted
you to shower before you made out or
anything yeah she probably did
maybe get it maybe grab some floss smoke
huh
old moose smoke
inside of you is supported by better
help online counseling
don't go anywhere folks this is you need
to listen to this
all right i mean uh if you're struggling
with anxiety depression
or stress right now obviously you're not
alone we talk about this in fact every
guest
deals with it for the most part
betterhelp offers online
licensed professional counselors who are
trained to listen and help
i you know my mind just goes in
different directions and sometimes i
should probably talk to someone this is
probably not healthy i should pro
we all do that so talk to someone you
know
and you can do it without going anywhere
you could do it from the comforts of
your own home
uh counselors specialize in many diverse
areas not only with depression and
anxiety but grief and relationship
conflicts etc
all you do is fill out a questionnaire i
can do this you fill out a questionnaire
to help assess your specific needs
and you get matched with the counselor
in under 48 hours talk with your
counselor in a safe and private online
environment at your convenience from
wherever you are comfortable
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist plus
exchange unlimited messages
everything you share is confidential and
if you're ever unhappy
with a counselor or anything you just
request a new one at any time no
additional charge
join the million plus taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced
better help professional with so many
people using better help they're
currently recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
better help is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10
off your first month with the discount
code
inside get started today at
betterhelp.com
i n s i d e that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash i-n-s-i-d-e
inside of you is brought to you by
raycon i like these i like these guys
they're earbuds and they're comfortable
and they're small and let's face it
folks you want to listen
to what you're listening to when you're
you're working out ryan yeah
you're uh you're working from home
everybody's working from home and you
want to listen to what you're listening
to you want to hear these outside noises
no and the biggest thing that i take
from these guys is they're affordable
it's quality and affordable and i think
that's important look you need a great
pair of wireless earbuds but stop
spending hundreds of dollars on a pair
you already know raycon earbuds start at
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbuds on the market
and they sound just as amazing as other
top audio brands you know
their newest model the everyday e25
earbuds are their best ones yet with six
hours of play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design that gives you a
nice
noise isolating fit and they're so
comfortable aren't they ryan perfect for
conference calls or
i don't know binging on podcasts
unlike some of your other wireless
options raycon earbuds are both stylish
and discreet with no dangling wires or
stems to distract anyone during the
video calls
now is the time to get the latest and
greatest from raycon
get 15 off your order at buy raycon dot
com
slash i o u that's buy raycon.com
iou for 15 off raycon wireless earbuds
by raycon.com
i o u
were you uh what's the hardest part
about being out there is it a
boredom is it b uh missing your family
or a combination of both so for me yeah
good question it was
you have to fight all those things you
have to like
not allow yourself to get bored or that
will quickly become the hardest thing
out there
or the same with missing your family if
you allow yourself to just
sit there and pine over your family
that's going to be the hardest thing out
there so it's
all those things you have to like
preemptively approach
uh for me the hardest thing was
uh the unknown it's just the unknown
period of time that you're out there
leads to a lot of issues so the fact
that it was
it could kind of go indefinitely or for
a full year
it was just like man i don't know how
much food i need to store up i don't
know if i'm like
if it's gonna be a six-month tv show i
don't even know if it's worth it to miss
you know my kids for that long
and and so you you have all these
worries about the future that
if i would have just lived in the
present i don't think i would have had a
lot of
it wouldn't have been super difficult
for me but it was it was all my
stress about the future that actually
ended up not coming to fruition that
that caused me the probably the most
difficulty out there
yeah you know it's like i think in real
life that's what it always is it's what
is what always affects us the most and
it's thinking of the future that we
can't control yeah
and that's with everybody right it's
like you know i'm thinking of like oh
what if nobody listens next week well
that's next week why are we worried
about next week
what if i'm what if i'm hungry in a
month well i'll find another moose
totally exactly i should have lived more
in the present and i did a lot but
but definitely all my stress a lot of
what you hear me
talking about on the show that's like i
don't have enough of this and that it's
like me just
being stressed about something that's
way off in the future like i
i still should have done all the same
things probably but i shouldn't have
allowed it to be so stressful because i
really didn't have to be it was pretty
did you almost die was there ever a
moment where it's not film that you're
like
i i honestly was close to dying or i
could die right now
i don't think so i think the most
dangerous point was
probably well you could always fall like
every time you're walking out there it's
so
slippery when it gets icy that it's like
it's stupid it's like you'll be thinking
do not fall do not
boom it's it's like that
slick and so there's always that and i
fell a few times but the uh
i imagine the thing that could have gone
worse was the
the wolverine encounter right
but was just one of those things he just
like he had
that had built up for a couple weeks by
the time i finally got him that it
it was very clear that it was kind of
him or me out there on the island
he was he was taking my uh stuff he was
taking all your meats
you you like your home is my home now
yeah you built
like this giant thing to keep your food
what do you call it yeah food cash or
like a lobbyist in russian but yeah
right you built this thing and that
bastard got up there and took it and
again you're like
man that's damn wolverine you're so even
killed i would have been like
yo son of a you know so wolverines can
take down
things six times their size right
they're they're fierce even though they
don't look that fierce they're fierce
right yeah
they are they're for i've actually read
one killed the polar bear in the zoo
uh some time back here
[Laughter]
got in the zoo in the polar bear pen at
the zoo but no the uh
they they are crazy they can take down
moose they just like jump on their backs
and
gnaw through their spine they're super
tenacious little critters and uh
i hadn't dealt with them so i didn't
know much about them i just heard of
them all the time in siberia because
they would all
tell me about him about how manifest so
if a wolverine comes he's going to ruin
your whole hunt for the year and this
and that
and but i don't think they're as many
they're as high
population wise in siberia as in
northwest territories because i just
never run into one in all my years out
there whereas
here there were multiple wolverines
running around you know
but you took it down at night where you
couldn't see much you had your
did you have your light on your head
yeah but like how close were you to it
where
anything could have changed something
could have turned around and not going
your way well it was
it happened so fast like it would kind
of led up to that because the night
before
i had kind of i'd like surrounded my
whole camp with these strings and cans
so that if anything walked through i'd
hear an alarm system go off
and uh the night before i had heard the
like client clank and i was like oh gosh
here he comes and so
i got ready with my bow and i went
outside and saw him come down and i saw
his like eyes
looking at me behind the bush probably
about
15 yards away or something and uh
i thought about taking a shot at him but
i was like well he'll come out from the
bush and then i'll shoot him
sure enough he didn't he like closed his
eyes i lost sight of him because it was
at night also and he like vanished and i
was like man
should have taken a shot like wow man
and then uh the next night
same thing happened i was sitting in my
shelter and i hear clint clank clank and
i was like oh gosh and so i ran out of
my shelter
and this time i saw him run behind the
same bush but i
didn't wait this time i just sent an
arrow in there and it like
ricocheted through the branches and
pinned him to the ground
and i mean it honestly just happened so
fast that
i just grabbed my axe and ran over there
and he was like spinning around on the
arrow
and then he lunged up at me and i swung
and hit him and
swung again and swung again and it was
over pretty fast
but oh you know i definitely thought he
might you know
he could like grabbed a hold of my arm
or something and
it would have been pretty wild he'd been
you'd have been out right he grabs you
he gets one slice on you you're gone
well you know he would it would have
been like having like a pit bull or
something on your arm you would have
been like
and i would have been probably trying to
stab him you know it could have gotten a
lot
gnarlier had the arrow not held would
you have stayed out if that thing bit
you or sliced you a little bit would you
like found a way to stay there i think i
would uh like it depends on how bad it
was but
uh in my head i would have like uh it's
like man i still have a lot of meat i
can like
lay here and be injured and heal slowly
and just eat
if i have to and then when those guys
come up
i talked about a bit with joe rogan but
like when i chopped myself with the axe
in siberia
i was laid up for like three days i
couldn't even move either of my legs
because my other one had been like
had surgery not long before i was
literally just
laying there in the teepee for three
days and i just
pictured myself probably like that if i
had gotten better
unless they told me i had to leave you
know do you watch have you seen all the
seasons of alone or you don't really do
that you just
yeah i do that's like the one show i
watch i do like it how many times do you
watch it and go
what are they doing why are they doing
it that way
i mean even i who don't know what the
hell couldn't survive uh like an
hour i'm like going that looks flammable
i don't know if that's there's some
things i always want
there's definitely things you watch and
you criticize maybe it's you're just not
there so you don't realize but
uh yeah i like watching this season
season seven i was watching it was kind
of driving me crazy like
just do this or yeah oh it was like
build your
fort build your shelter the guy didn't
even fill this
tarp flapping like his tarp was just
flapping in the wind and driving him
crazy i was like put some logs on your
dog
good lord what is this lazy guy he's out
for
four weeks and he hasn't put up a he's
living under a tarp
and then i'm like well what all the
details are maybe he has a good reason
for not doing it but
i was i doubt i was pretty uh
you know i think why i signed up was
probably because when you watch those
first
episodes of the first seasons you're
kind of like
oh man everybody's just afraid of a bear
it's like oh perfect i'd love to hunt a
bear you know so like
i could do that and so you kind of sign
up but you don't you know of course it's
different than you expect and it's easy
to talk
from the couch but yeah so you're not
afraid of a bear yeah
they really they really show only a
fraction of what you're doing so they
might
a lot of times people criticize you for
not doing things that you are doing
right you know and hey the women are
tough man
you know i thought i thought what's her
name was gonna be [ __ ] for a second i
was like
i mean but they told her yeah they were
like hey you're losing too much body fat
to both of them they're both tough as
[ __ ] man
all the women they get on there are just
like i'm like they're tougher than any
dude i know
yeah absolutely i i told you that after
the show when i saw her then you are
tough good for you i mean that's cool
and then same with
nikki same thing she just didn't have as
much weight going in or otherwise she
would have lasted
you know she did last as long as her
body allowed but you didn't have
you weren't a big guy you were scared
you were thin oh yeah i was in the same
boat i mean i would have
i wouldn't uh i'm sure they would have
pulled me sooner because i would have
gotten skinnier sooner
the fact is i just knew i had to provide
way more food
to have a chance out there so it really
put the pressure on me being like the
skinny guy i was like man i i can't be
lazy i have to
produce and be active and proactive you
know so
yeah how much did it change your life
winning that 500 000
because like people forget there's taxes
yeah if all the money itself
hasn't much because it was like uh like
you say you pay taxes and of course i've
always been self-employed so i don't
have any retirement or anything so then
you put
some into retirement and then you put
and then
we were living like a one-bedroom house
and so then we have
three kids now so we caught this other
house and renovated it
and you know that kind of it kind of
goes pretty quick like it's a good does
a good job of setting you up better
and it's been super nice but it's not
like enough money to
live the rest of your life you know on
on your post taxes winnings but
it has also provided a lot of new
opportunities to where
now i don't have to uh you know now i'm
not
demoing buildings in you know lynchburg
virginia for a living i'm doing you know
i do another
other things to do so that's been super
nice
and would you do it again if they ask
you i bet you'll do it again
uh yeah it'd be interesting i'd uh my
ears will be open i'll have to hear what
they have to say
aren't you pissed that it's like season
six win 500 000
and then the next season one million
you're like what the [ __ ]
they shortened it and they doubled the
money they made it a 100 day cap
yeah and they made it to where you could
you could last that like so i would have
had the option to stay the extra 23 days
to double my money like heck yeah
i mean i don't i can't complain i'm
happy but it was a
it was was a rip-off
[Laughter]
you know you guys had an extra 500k
lying around like
but you know what i always think like
you know celebrities have to have it
when celebrities have kids the kids got
to be hard it's like my dad's a
celebrity like bru you know maybe bruce
willis is kid or whatever
and they're like my dad's a celebrity
look what i have to how could i be that
dude i mean
do your kids look at you like oh my gosh
my dad's a badass i got i got to be a
badass or what do you tell them as a
father i think they're too young i think
they're too young to know
they'll grow up and watch it
yeah they don't know about the we'll see
they'll be so sick of me our dad's
dragging us up in the woods again i'm in
a stupid show and it's stupid
do you do you camp with them you take
them camping and start to show them
little skills
yeah yeah we like to do that kind of
stuff
we just had another baby so he's kind of
throwing a stick in our camping spokes
but
definitely like that's what i think a
lot about when i'm up in the wilderness
and doing things like that it's like oh
man i can't wait to get the kids out
here and
this and that well you know i was
thinking i i read something where i
don't know if it's true but are you
teaching survival skills
and and getting yeah yeah we're doing
like uh taking people out like riding
horses way deep into the wilderness and
spending a week out in the
you know out in the wilderness just
learning skills but also just
being disconnected and from
the craziness and kind of you know
having real life conversations and
also learning about survival you know
being in an awesome place
yeah what's it called is it called uh
jonas survival
wasn't it yeah it's just out of the on
my website at like
jordanjonas.com there's a link to my
survival courses there
like you know i've kind of teamed up
with this outfitter
who has all the horses and all the you
know land
800 like to do it on and it's a really
good setup so
how much is it for someone like me who
wanted to come out there for a week and
learn survival skills for a week what's
what's it cost
eighteen hundred bucks but it's it's
pretty intense i think it's a good deal
like
that's the feedback's been really good
uh the uh cause you're getting like
we're going way back in on horses and
having like a pretty
epic adventure out there so it's like i
think it's a good deal i've got had a
lot of feedback saying like
things like life-changing and and like
unforgettable
you know so it's been this is our first
year doing it we didn't know what to
expect but it's been so
overwhelmingly positive how many people
have come so far
uh four oh you know rough has been four
classes so
roughly 40 but a little less because
some people cancel so
like right 35 wow does anybody when
you're in there going guy i gotta get
out of here i'm sorry i can't handle
this not for me no
nobody has there's like been people that
were like man i wonder how they're gonna
do you know some people came who had
never
even been uh one guy came and never been
outside of san diego
so he had never even been in the woods
or anything never camping and
but man he had a blast and it was
awesome and you know
and he learned a lot and had a new
experience and at the same time we had a
guy that had been to
several survival courses you know and
more hardcore ones and he had an awesome
time so this kind of
runs the gamut of experience out there
but listen to me
i couldn't start a fire even if i had a
lighter
i can't i ca i i don't know what it's
like to trap
i don't know how to build a tent i've
never done really [ __ ] man
you can do it you would have a blast you
should come out and do a week
it would be so fun you'd have a you'd
totally have a blast
so what are things that you like while
you're there i mean what what are a
couple things i would learn how to do
because i'm first of all color blind
okay you're color blind that's fine
actually colorblind people see
movement better so you might spot more
animals than us
no but the uh you you'd learn how to
like did we just get a stick
and some fishing line learn how to tie
up some
flies you know like for for fly fishing
tie
a little fly out of some fur and then
go catch some fish at the lake cook them
up
smoke them you know do all the preserve
them
uh you learn how to build traps for
everything from
mice to fox to bear
and cleaning like cleaning a fish you
learn how to clean a fish start a fire
yeah exactly learn how to clean a fish
learn learn kind of how they behave and
and
uh how to fish in the survival situation
like that
in these high mountains and then um
teach you how to build not only like a
little fly rod but also like a spinner
rod how to makeshift
make some lures a gill net do you learn
how to make a gill net
yeah you could learn how to make a gill
net we don't we don't do a gill net
every time but
we did once so you know like it depends
on what people want to know
because there's a lot to teach and you
know so i just feel helpless
they want to know then i would teach
that specifically but yeah i know
we learn how to make a little kayak and
go out in the lake and
anything like that would you do
something jordan where it's like we paid
you the right amount of money to come
come out maybe to california go up in
the mountains and
check it out and then maybe do like a uh
a different
scenario like out out west or something
yeah that'd be fun
has it something to check into yeah yeah
i'd be open to the idea
i'm telling you man i think it'd be a
fun ass show if i could get like 10 of
my celebrity friends and like go out
with the guy the winner from
and see how many people are just it'd be
hilarious we should we could do that we
should make a show that'd be hilarious
oh my gosh you know i'm thinking about
you know i could just see me go i can't
do this anymore dude it's been an
hour calm down what are you doing with
yourself
i don't know man all right look this is
called [ __ ] talking with jordan jonas
this is these are from my patrons
uh they asked some questions cool nico p
what advice and this could be a rapid or
whatever whatever you want
uh what advice can you give to people
who are looking to unplug more often
from technology
uh yeah i would say i mean i don't know
where the guy lives but if you
get out in the woods do some more spend
time in nature and leave your phone at
home and
uh you'll find after a day or two that
you don't miss it at all
you'll be you'll actually be really glad
you don't have it it feels weird
initially but
but it's pretty i don't think it's
psychologically very healthy to be
checking the news all the time and being
mad at this or that or
you know yeah hey you're frozen again so
get so get out of
ultimately just get into nature and put
your phone away
and leave your phone like don't be
afraid to leave it behind and unplug you
really won't miss it
it's like i promise jonathan p what's
your favorite food to eat from the
wilderness
favorite and favorite animal to hunt uh
i really like eating
uh i just love it when berries are in
season up north or even here
the huckleberries but uh it's just like
paradise just berries everywhere
it's awesome of course everything in
nature tastes better but
uh like fish fish trout is good
and uh favorite animal to hunt i mean
it's hard to beat the moose
because they're so big
marissa ann you've experienced has
survived a lot in your life what are
some skills or lessons you hope to teach
your kids so one day they can overcome
anything like you have i'd like to teach
him
resilience in the same way that i
learned it from
well hopefully not in the same way but i
learned it from my dad in as
powerful of a way as you can and that he
like went
lost his legs and lost all the movement
in his hands to diabetes and stuff and
then he also
had just excruciating back pain
all through it he somehow maintained joy
like
and like he he you know lost his job
because he couldn't work and he
was wasn't able to be productive mom had
to go back to work so there was all this
emotionally
difficult stuff for him to deal with but
and physically difficult things but he
dealt with it and approached life in a
way that he was still
positive and joyful and was we could
learn we learned a ton
from that you know watching him go
through that and it puts so much
perspective on your own suffering also
shows you how to deal with
you know trials that life has so
hopefully
i'll be able to teach the kids to uh
you know build an example to them
a similar resilience and depth of
character that will
help them get through hard times and
enjoy the good times dude you know
you're a good man you're just a good man
who's uh brave and uh
yeah i just i love hearing that it's
great advice um
you know ray ray a we kind of talked
about this but you just rapid fire how
do you keep your sanity being out there
i mean you said you
you talked about there's a few things
but one you you don't allow yourself to
get really bored so always stay
busy don't allow problems to overwhelm
you but
but really separate what you can control
from what you can't control
and then the things you can control do
you know like so be proactive in solving
your problems don't just allow your
as you saw on the show i had a lot of
issues come up and you kind of just have
to be like okay well
what's the solution if there's a
solution then i should do that before i
start complaining too much you know so
it's like uh being proactive
being you know having a real attitude
that's focused on gratitude and the
positive things going on rather than
focusing on the negative that's
super important uh you know what you
just said
jordan you know you just what's funny is
your answer
as much as it is so important for being
out in nature and alone
yeah it's the same advice you give to
someone now
keep busy be proactive don't worry about
tomorrow
if you have a problem find a solution
don't be bored keep busy these are all
things that
light it's life right that's so true man
i guess so it's like
they really are they are universal
lessons they're so starkly
um before you in a situation like that
but
it's the exact same lessons you would
apply in real life oh again earlier we
were talking about right not focus too
much
on don't be so stressed out by the
future that you're not enjoying the
present you know
and not being grateful for what you have
uh
yeah yeah yeah so those are all parts of
that
how not to go crazy well leanne p says i
mean we
again we said this but you know based on
your experiences show you would do it
again right you said you're all ears
yeah i'm all ears for what they're what
they're offering but they better not go
back to half a million it better be for
a million
yeah yeah they better not go to the
sahara desert or something dumb
well dude this you know this is uh i
don't like i don't take your time your i
know your kids are there and oh i'm
enjoying it dude
i love this i'm not gonna harass you or
anything but i will probably try to
email you and figure out either how to
get there to one of your
uh explorations or something i just i
you know i just was like you know you
have so much patience i think that's
what it was
that i'm like i want this guy to teach
me because i won't feel like an idiot
even though i do feel like an idiot
someone who has patience with me it
would actually be a blast
i think we should do it we should plan
something somewhere
i think it would be worse dude i would i
would do it man i in a heartbeat
i would like i have a couple of friends
who i talked to like hey man i
honestly couldn't survive for like five
minutes i i don't know if i can get out
of the boat
like or the helicopter i'm like so i'm
like
i want to learn some survival so i just
want to learn how to build a fire i want
to learn how to build a shelter
so you're not like yeah yeah something
and i think maybe
who knows what it will do maybe all of a
sudden it will i'll be enlightened that
i'm like hey
i probably will be like dude this is
what life is man this is nature you got
everything in front of you
[ __ ] music yeah yeah yeah no
schedules you're just what do you need
you need to catch some fish let's go
catch some fish
you know that's it
dude this has been a real blast i hope
you had fun and i really appreciate you
doing this man
i appreciate the invite man it's an
honor and uh yeah you should uh
just keep in touch i will keep in touch
man you just you just you gotta
i told you my guys you don't know this
but i direct messaging right after i saw
the finale and i said listen
i played a badass on tv but you're a
badass in real life
and i would do anything for you to come
on the the podcast because i i knew
i just loved the story and just hearing
more from you i just it's i think it's
more
encouraging than a lot of celebrities
and athletes who come on here it's all
great stories but
this is like real life stuff and it's
it's awesome so good luck with your
family and the you know the new
endeavors and and all that stuff and
i'll be in touch man i'm not one of
those hollywood people who says yeah
i'll email you i'll [ __ ] email you
i actually look forward to it i think we
would have a really good time let's do
it
me too man hey lastly can you give a
shout out
to my friends who made me watch the show
it's just tom and dineen
oh yeah tom and dineen thanks for having
such good taste in tv
and and plugging them
plugging michael in it's awesome
it's awesome hopefully uh yeah thank you
yes give rachel my love your sister i
will i will
can you give me a bio or something she
goes well i'll write some [ __ ] down
and she did so dude hey all my love all
my uh wishes of
health and happiness to you man i'll
talk to you soon thanks man see ya
man that was good i just uh you know
i've had in in the early stages of
interviewing people
i get some comments for like look the
guard talk
let the guest i sound like my stepdad
good
lord michael what the he sounds like
king of the hill but uh you know
this guy was so great and i was
starstruck i was just like so excited to
talk to him
i don't know why but that's how i i work
i just
i just couldn't calm down i wanted to
ask him so many things and he answered
them all
um so i i hope you guys liked it as much
as i did
and uh you know i'm sure people look at
uh names and they're like oh
tom welling smallville i'll listen to
that one jordan jonas i don't know him
well you should because i think his
story is sensational
and he's a tremendous human being he's a
wonderful family
it's just a great story so i hope people
connect with that and uh
i hope eventually the show gets to a
certain point where i can just i mean i
guess i can do it now
bring on whoever i want even nobody
knows them but you want to keep people
listening
but people sometimes are they sort of uh
if they don't know then they don't stick
around so i hope you keep sticking
around man i hope you enjoyed that let
me know on the comments on youtube
you could watch on youtube or listen
anywhere what you thought
uh thanks to all the patrons remember
rob danson and i are doing another stage
it will play some covers i think we're
going to play take it easy by the eagles
maybe uh
losing my religion uh play some
originals and uh
some a couple left on laurel songs it's
a blast great prizes
take it easy the first song that my dad
taught me how to play really yeah we
still play it well i've been running
down the road
loosing my lord seven women on my
mind that's right a shout out to my
loves
that's the uh patrons thank you
guys you know who you are well because
i'm going to announce some of you now
nancy d leah s trisha f sarah v little
lisa
lillisa yukiko jill e bryan h lauren g
nico p
barry i angelina g robin s jerry w emily
k
bob b robert b jason w stephen j
kristen k amelia o allison l tom n
jess j lucas m raj
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m hamza
b jennifer n i said i think
stacy b carly t jennifer s janelle b
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tabitha
273 that's correct kimberly e crystal h
mike e marissa ramirez beth b
chris f sarah f chad w leanne p
jackie p rodriguez rachen ray a maya p
megan d jennifer c maddie s tiffany i
kendrick f ashley e margie m thomas t
matt
w belinda carli belinda n
benjamin r lisa j i dated a girl named
lisa j
she's married and has a kid and i'm
alone kevin v
robert s joy w nicole m amber f james r
chris h snowar noah h
noah k no a k it's not an h
so thank you guys thanks so much for
listening today um
thanks for listening to the podcast
subscribing to it i love
doing this and i want to continue doing
it um
i guess sort of i thought about ryan if
you know you think about all the the
hosts
you got comedians who are hosts i i
don't listen to a lot of podcasts i
don't want to be
get ideas i just want to like this is
how i roll this is like
i don't know what i'm doing i just feel
like i just
i feel like i'm just a regular person
asking questions that regular people
want to know
not does that make sense sure but my
my goal i don't know my goal is i never
thought of a goal other than you know i
hope hopefully having a successful
podcast but
you know if it came where i could have a
talk show
and talk like i am now and just do what
i want to do and
you know and have guests on and really
get inside them
then i would uh i would like that
i don't know um how that works i you
know no one's approached me
so you know i feel like if it gets to a
certain point and we
you know gets bigger or whatever and or
maybe i just do one and say i mean it is
kind of a talk show anyway it's on
youtube but like to have like a network
behind you and like
do like one night a week like oh and now
net coming up next inside you with
michael rosenbaum and it's like guests
uh
will ferrell will followed by a big bang
theory marathon
right uh it'd be kind of cool i think i
would do it if it was once a week i
couldn't do it like johnny carson does
i just aged myself i couldn't do it like
uh who
like steve allen well that's even older
uh
no i couldn't do it like jimmy kimmel
and um yeah everybody has their own
personality so i i'm sure you guys
listen to a lot of podcasts
uh you know rogan has a double whole wwe
thing going on and he's like you know
and he does these three hour interviews
i don't know how they do it and my buddy
dax they do these interviews where
they're three hours long and i just
i couldn't do that i i
i can't i can't i can't put a guess
through it
even though guests are dying to get on
those other shows because they're great
shows
so i for me i just want to do an hour
they're like oh
that wasn't too much of an inconvenience
i mean if i was doing three hours i
don't know if you'd be able to do this
no did you imagine editing these things
three hours long
no like doing a titanic a week no oh
[ __ ]
off seriously all right thank you again
to everybody i
say it all the time i hope it continues
i feel like i'm very blessed and i
and i want you to know you are too we're
alive we're here get outside do
something keep busy
uh and if you listen to the uh you're
obviously listening to the interview
didn't just go i'm gonna listen to the
outro anyway good to see you right good
to see you too and um
that's it guys i hope you enjoyed it
until next week um tell all your friends
email everybody make them
subscribe and um thank you thanks for
allowing me to be inside each and every
one of you